kicking off the ubisoft conference Trey  Parker and Matt Stone detailed South  Park the fractured butthole this time  around the kids of South Park are  playing superheroes and you're back to  being the new kid no one wants to hang  out with you'll get to choose from a  dozen superhero classes when you start  out and the intent is for you to be able  to create the exact kind of superhero  you want to be a new gameplay trailer  was debuted and Parker and Stone  explained that they have added the  option to move your characters around in  combat to help you get tactical it was  also revealed that the game will be out  on december six roll the latest on South  Park and everything else that matters  stay tuned to gamespot  you